Speaker 1: Let's go next to. Oh, I don't
know. Why don't we go to Chris from
Texas? Chris, you're on the air.
Speaker 4: Hey, David, again,
nice to talk with you again.
Speaker 1: Pleasure.
Speaker 4: All right. So I guess one thing
I'm just kind of a little scared about is like
there's been just an increase in white
supremacist violence and rhetoric throughout
this whole country like we saw in 2018
with the Pittsburgh synagogue shooting.
Then we saw it again in 2019 with the El Paso
shooting and the synagogue shooting, and now
just recently with this buffalo shooting. Yeah, I
just feel like we have to do something about it.
I feel like we have to take more measures against
that, like the news media that's responsible for
it, such as Fox News about these things.
Speaker 1: When you say we have to take
action, what would you do to Fox News?
Speaker 4: I feel like we need to. I mean,
one thing I'm thinking about doing is we would
probably need to maybe try to pressure their
sponsors to probably cut off ties to people such
as Tucker Carlson. Because I feel like as long as
Tucker Carlson still gets this money from Fox News
and he brings in a lot of the money, since he's
like the highest rating person there, there's not
going to be much incentive for Fox News to change.
Speaker 1: Well, what you have to remember, we
actually talked about this earlier this week.
Fox is different than some of the other networks
in that. Fox gets two thirds of its revenue from
subscription fees, from cable companies and not
so much from advertising. So actually going after
Fox's advertisers doesn't have as big of an
effect as it would on some other companies. That's
other channels, which is an unfortunate
thing. So really what people have to do is
you have to call your cable company
and say, I don't want Fox News,
make Fox an optional channel. And if
I don't want it, I save my two bucks
a month. That would actually crush Fox.
Speaker 4: Kind of like what we did with
and with the whole AT&T scandal that they had.
Speaker 1: In a sense. But the difference is that
Fox is included in just standard cable packages,
and people don't even realize that close to $2 a
month from what they pay is going to Fox. Even
if you don't watch it, that has to be cut off.
Speaker 4: Hello.
Speaker 1:
All right. Thank you very much for the
call. Sounds like we're having a bit of
a connection issue. But yeah, that's the
issue with going after FOX is advertisers.
They're not nearly as reliant on
advertisers as many of the other platforms